they have a code red situation  in half an hour we could be looking at  another chin novel i just couldn't get  through the first series to be honest  it's a national emergency jerry  no it's me i said you want to go out for  a drink tonight on the wall  yeah i'm down i'll call you back  half a million lives all at stake what  oh god it's endless isn't it  we have 25 minutes more pressing than  that i've got a date tonight  what's that noise are you eating soup  we're kissing i know i'd love to take a  crack at saving the whole world  not just this little island wow  yes well someone's got to be the hero  how good is your american accent really  not very good ma'am  you